[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit Jana
pareigis schönen guten Abend und
willkommen der Blick auf die Fußball-WM
mit Norbert Lehmann einen schönen guten
Tag
Alarm in den Kinderkliniken so viele
Patienten kommen auf zu wenig Personal
die Folge nicht mehr alle Kinder können
ausreichend behandelt werden
Hilfe fürs Heizen der Bund übernimmt in
diesem Monat die Kosten für Gas und
Fernwärme dazu ein Überblick wie die
Entlastung bei uns Kunden ankommt
siegen oder fliegen heute Abend muss das
deutsche WM-Team gegen Costa Rica
möglichst deutlich gewinnen und dabei
noch auf Schützenhilfe von spanienhoffen
Spanner geht es also kaum heute abend es
heißt ja entweder ko oder in der KO
Runde genommen ja ein echter Showdown
erwartet uns da Deutschland muss also
unbedingt singen da geht gar kein Weg
dran vorbei und im parallel laufende
Gruppenspiel wenn da Spanien gegen Japan
gewinnt dann wäre Deutschland auf jeden
Fall eine Runde weiter
und das sind Bilder aus dem Stadion und
aus der Kabine des der deutschen des
deutschen Teams alle Spieler der 26
köpfigen BK das sind fit jetzt letzte
Absprachen von Bundestrainer Hansi Flick
mit der Mannschaft ja und vor allem mit
den 11 Spielern die zum Anpfiff der
Partien knapp einer Stunde auf dem Platz
stehen werden
Sven Voss vor dem albeit Stadion wie
sieht denn nun haben sie Flix Startelf
aus
ja Norbert die Aufstellung gegen Costa
Rica von Hansi Flick hält doch einige
Überraschungen bereits auf Überraschung
eins Niklas Füllkrug von vielen für die
Startelf gefordert er spielt nicht von
Anfang an es gibt ähm eine Veränderung
im Vergleich zum Spanien Spiel Thilo
Kehrer der rechte Verteidiger bleibt
draußen und es kommt Leroy sané in die
Mannschaft der diesen Einsatz von Anfang
an auf jeden Fall rechtfertigt er hat
starke Impulse gebracht und Torchancen
gegen Spanien aber da ist die Frage wer
rückt denn in der Viererkette hinten
nach rechts wir vermuten das ist Josua
Kimmich sein wird von der 6 auf hinten
rechts das ist eigentlich nicht seine
Lieblingsposition aber eine auf der
angefangen hat wir sind sehr sehr
gespannt wie sich das dann nachher im
Spiel darstellt egal wer von Anfang an
spielt Deutschland braucht auf jeden
Fall Tore gegen Costa Rica um ins
Achtelfinale zu kommen danke Sven
und es gab ja schon zwei spannende
Spiele und Entscheidungen in der Gruppe
F ja Marokko und Kroatien stehen im
Achtelfinale und dazu nachher
klicken wir jetzt nach Deutschland denn
in der Notfallmedizin wird Alarm
geschlagen die Situation in den
Kinderkliniken sei katastrophal es baut
sich eine Welle von Atemwegsinfektionen
auf aber die Krankenhäuser seien schon
jetzt am Limit auf Kinder
Intensivstationen gibt es in ganz
Deutschland nur noch 83 freie Betten
rechnerisch weniger als eines pro-klinik
jedes zweite der 110 Befragten Häuser
muss Notarztwagen wieder wegschicken
überall fehlt es an Personal Sibylle
Basler berichtet aus einem
Kinderkrankenhaus in München
anna hat Leukämie 6 Monate war sie hier
auf der onkologischen Station heute wird
die zweijährige entlassen doch in die
Freude mischt sich auch die Angst ihre
Eltern wenn wir zu Hause sind und müssen
dann herzwegs Fieber dann wissen wir
nicht ob wir hier auf der Station
aufgenommen werden können weil die
Betten reduziert sind die Sorge ist
berechtigt denn wegen Personalmangel
können auch hier viele Betten nicht
belegt werden seit Monaten und das
trifft die kleinen Patienten mit voller
Wucht das bedeutet dass wir hier in der
Onkologie
unsere Kinder nicht mehr versorgen
können also wir können die Familien die
wir lange lange kennen bei uns auf
Station zum Teil nicht mehr aufnehmen
kein Einzelfall dazu noch die massive
rs-viruswelle das bringt die Kliniken
bundesweit in große Not jedes zweite
Krankenhaus muss kleine Patienten
wegschicken weil es kein freies Bett
mehr hat so eine aktuelle Umfrage und
der deutschen intensiv und
notfallmedizinern die Lage ist höchst
dramatisch denn wir müssen den ganzen
Tag überlegen eben wenn da ein Bett ist
welcher Patient bekommt es und welcher
eben auch nicht ein Notruf aus den
Kinderkliniken langfristig plant Berlin
die Abschaffung der Fallpauschalen und
eine 300 Millionen Euro Spritze schnelle
Hilfe in der aktuellen Misere soll unter
anderem durch verschobene Ops geleistet
werden und die Kinder brauchen jetzt
unsere aufmerksam Möglichkeit wir werden
Personal aus den regulären
erwachsenenstationen in die
Kinderstationen verlegen insbesondere
Pflegepersonal und Anna sie und ihre
Eltern dürfen jetzt nach Hause sie
hoffen nur eines das bloß nichts
Unvorhergesehenes passiert
wegen der hohen Energiepreise bekommen
alle die derzeit in einer Hochschule
eingeschrieben oder in einer
Fachschulausbildung sind 200 Euro vom
Staat das hat der Bundestag heute
beschlossen abgesehen davon gilt für
Dezember wer Gas oder Fernwärme nutzt
muss in diesem Monat keinen Abschlag
zahlen das übernimmt der Bund wie diese
Soforthilfe genau funktioniert und was
Sie tun müssen um sie zu bekommen all
das erklären Ihnen jetzt wenn ihr
dummeier und Clemens Altmann
Carsten Sailer Hausbesitzer und Gaskunde
seine Abschlagszahlung an den Versorger
hat der freiwillig schon erhöht um 50
Euro im Monat auf die dezemberhilfe
allein will er sich nicht verlassen ich
denke mal das ist ein tropfenaufen
heißen Stein gerade auch weil etliche
andere benachteiligt sind gerade die Öl
haben oder Pellets die werden zum
Beispiel nicht gefördert wir sind also
noch einigermaßen gut dran im Dezember
will die Regierung zumindest Gas und
Fernwärmekunden mit einer Einmalzahlung
helfen und so funktioniert
der vom Energielieferanten im September
geschätzte Jahresverbrauch wird durch 12
geteilt und mit dem aktuellen Preis für
Dezember multipliziert
ein Beispiel
eine Familie mit einem Jahresverbrauch
von 20.000 Kilowattstunden zahlt für Gas
aktuell im Schnitt 18,6 Cent pro
Kilowattstunde und jährlich somit
3.726 Euro durch die Übernahme des
dezemberabschlags spart sie knapp 311
Euro
. die Kunden müssen sich um nichts
kümmern die Berechnung erfolgt
automatisch durch den jeweiligen
Versorger das gilt allerdings nur für
Kunden mit einem direkten Vertrag beim
Energielieferanten die meisten Mieter
zahlen Gas und Fernwärme aber an ihren
Vermieter der die Ersparnis erhält und
weitergibt die allermeisten mieter
müssen dann darauf warten dass der
Vermieter im Zuge der
Betriebskostenabrechnung also im Laufe
des nächsten Jahres eine Entlastung
bekommt das kann im aller schlechtesten
Fall dezember 2023 werden
Fernwärmekunden bekommen die Höhe ihrer
Abschlagszahlung aus dem september + 20%
erstattet um die gestiegenen
Energiekosten zumindest ein wenig
auszugleichen
nach jahrelang Diskussionen hat der
Bundestag das umstrittene
Handelsabkommen ceta-ratifiziert es soll
den Handel zwischen der EU und Kanada
erleichtern beispielsweise durch den
Wegfall von knapp 98% aller Zölle
außerdem wird der Handel von
industrie-gütern einfacher und
Unternehmen bekommen einen Zugang zu
öffentlichen Aufträgen in Kanada die
Wirtschaft erhofft sich einen Schub von
ceta Kritikerinnen und Kritiker
bemängeln dass der Umweltschutz zu wenig
beachtet wird
als erster ausländischer Staatschef ist
der französische Präsident macron zu
Besuch bei US-Präsident beiden mit
militärischen Ehren und Staatsbankett
aber nicht ohne
Meinungsverschiedenheiten so kritisieren
macron und auch die EU das
inflationsreduzierungsgesetz beides da
es Subventionen für US-Produkte vorsieht
super aggressiv sei das Gegenüber
französischen Unternehmen sag macron MRT
Wissen berichtet
er klatscht vor Freude wohl weil sie
ihre Freundschaft zeigen können denn
wirklich gute Freunde so heißt es können
sich ja alles sagen Immanuel will sich
bei Joe so nennen sie sich beschweren
dass er Europas Firmen massiv
benachteiligt denn beides
Klimaschutzpaket Punkt 370 Milliarden
Dollar Investitionen und Steuervorteile
in die US-Wirtschaft dazu macron
kürzlich gehöre sich nicht in einer
Freundschaft die beide für
unverzichtbarkeits
Frankreich ist unser Ältester
Verbündeter stand fester Partner im
Kampf für die Freiheit und das Bündnis
zwischen unseren Nationen ist essentiell
für unsere Verteidigung
angesichts der russischen Aggression
gegen die Ukraine und vieler Krisen
denen unsere Nationen gegenüberstehen
müssen wir einmal mehr Waffenbrüder
werden
kein Platz soll zwischen die Verbündeten
passen im Umgang mit viel mehr Putin da
sind sich beide einig aber dann am
knisternden Kaminfeuer mahnt macron
natürlich müssen wir viel in die
Wirtschaft investieren aber dabei die
Maßnahmen unbedingt aufeinander
abstimmen
macron will Ausnahmeregelungen für
europäische Firmen erwürgen damit sie
gleichberechtigt in den USA investieren
können ob die Freundschaft so weit geht
darüber soll am Montag der gemeinsame
handelsrat von EU und USA hier in
Washington verhandelt
40.000 Fälle von Kriegsverbrechen so
viele hat das ukrainische
Justizministerium nach eigenen Angaben
bereits registriert Butcher ihr PIN in
vielen Orten die unter russischer
Besatzung standen finden sich nach Abzug
der Truppen hinweise auf solche
Verbrechen so auch rund um die befreite
Stadt hason unsere Porter Hannah
hebelstreit waren einem Dorf westlich
von hassson wo die Polizei sieben
Leichen ausgegraben hat darunter ein
16-jähriges Mädchen
in kraftino beginnt für die Ermittler
die Suche nach Hinweisen auf russische
Kriegsverbrechen auf dem Friedhof sie
haben die Leiche der 16-Jährigen
Victoria exhumiert zusammen mit sechs
jungen Männern soll sie von dem
Besatzern getötet worden sein
haben die Ermittler Sie ausgegraben
ihre Leiche untersuchen ob sie
Schusswunden oder Spuren von
Misshandlungen finden
nachdem Abzug der Russen verfolgen
ukrainische Ermittler rund um crosson
zahlreiche Hinweise auf Vergehen der
Besatzer
etwa 500 Hinweise auf Kriegsverbrechen
liegen uns bis jetzt vor neben
Zerstörungen von Infrastruktur und
privaten Häusern geht es um illegale
Festnahmen von Zivilisten die gefoltert
und dann getötet worden
im Fall des Schwert zerstörten Ortes
pravdino hat man beim Ausgraben der
sterblichen Überreste von Victorias
Freunden bereits Spuren gefunden die
auch Verbrechen russischer Soldaten
hinweisen
einem der Schädel konnte man ein Loch
erkennen
das war ganz klar dass die Person
erschossen wurde
bei drei anderen Körpern haben wir
gesehen dass Seile um ihre Handknochen
gebunden waren
die Dorfbewohner sagen die Russen hätten
die Männer getötet weil man ihnen
Kontakte zum ukrainischen Militär
unterstellte
der russische Angriffskrieg auf die
Ukraine beherrscht auch das jährliche
Treffen der usze die Organisation für
Sicherheit und Zusammenarbeit in Europa
seit mehr als 50 Mitgliedstaaten alles
schicken heute ihre Außenministerin und
Außenminister ins polnische Lodge einer
fehlte aber der Russe
Polen ließ ihn wegen der eu-sanktion
nicht einreisen Andreas
57 Delegationen müssen an diesem Morgen
durch die Altstadtstraßen von Lodz
geschleust werden die OSZE ist so stark
wie noch nie nach Mitgliederzahl
gerechnet und so schwach wie noch nie
nach ihrer Wirkung
[Musik]
die russische Krieg gegen die Ukraine
beweist dass die OSZE keinen Frieden
garantieren kann wenn ihre Arbeit aus
dem Inneren der Organisation heraus
sabotiert wird
gemeint ist Russland das nur seinen
Botschafter am Tisch sitzen hat weil
Polen Außenminister lavroff die Einreise
verweigert seit Jahren versucht Russland
osze-missionen zu behindern oder zu
verhindern die drei beobachtermissionen
in der Ukraine mussten deshalb kurz vor
dem Krieg enden in Moskau wirft lavrov
dem Westen vor die OSZE gekapert zu
haben die Amerikaner haben Europa
versklavt
in Lodge überrascht die Europäer dass
sich bis auf Belarus kein Staat auf die
Seite Russlands stellt kein einziger
glaube fast
dass wir OSZE mit diesen 56 Ländern
enger zusammenstehen als viele viele
Jahre zuvor schon stellen die ersten
Länder das Einstimmigkeitsprinzip in
Frage andernfalls bleibe immer das 57
Land das Problem die OSZE funktioniert
nicht mehr mit Russland aber sie hat
keinen Sinn ohne Russland die OSZE wird
sich neu erfinden müssen
in Spanien sind weitere in Postsendungen
versteckte Sprengsätze entdeckt worden
bereits gestern war eine Briefbombe in
der ukrainischen Botschaft in Madrid
explodiert die Serie hat möglicherweise
einen Bezug zum ukrainekrieg Heute wurde
auch in der US-Botschaft in Madrid eine
verdächtige Sendung gefunden laut
spanischen Innenministerium wurde letzte
Woche eine weitere Briefbombe
unschädlich gemacht die ein
Ministerpräsident Petrus Sanchez
gerichtet war
und jetzt werfe ein Blick in die
Kunstwelt Max Beckmanns Selbstbildnis
gelb rosa hat den deutschen
Auktionsrekord gebrochen es ist am Abend
in Berlin für 20 Millionen Euro
versteigert worden damit ist es das
teuerste je in der Bundesrepublik
versteigerte Kunstwerk das Gemälde gilt
als Meisterwerk des deutschen
Expressionismus es entstand 1943 nach
Beckmanns Flucht aus Nordsee Deutschland
zurück zur WM in Katar dem Fußballfest
der etwas anderen Art im Wüstensand es
sind nicht so viele wie bei den
vergangenen Weltmeisterschaften aber
einige tausend deutsche Fans werden auch
heute vor Ort im Stadion sein und geht
es nach den treusten der treuen steht
dem Erfolg von Hans Zimmermann
der Flughafen von Doha vor fünf Stunden
fest in deutscher Hand diese 70 Fans
sind gerade mit dem Shuttle aus Dubai
gelandet ihr Selbstbewusstsein
grenzenlos wir kommen aus dem
Schwabenland und immer wenn wir da sind
dann geht's auf was ich glaube auch das
3.0 ausgeht heute die Kugel habe ich
nicht ich wünsche es dem Team weil sie
eine tolle Leistung gebracht haben und
wirklich gekämpft haben wir werden
gleich jubeln wir werden gleich laut
rufen und auch laut schreien ich kann
dir das vormachen Deutschland
Deutschland
auf dem Weg ins Stadion machen fast alle
hier Stationen am suka kiff dem
zentralen Marktplatz von Doha
wir sind ganz viele Fans ganz viele
Völker und das ich finde schon dass es
hier ordentlich wärmfl ist den ganzen
Weg gekommen um dann da ruhig und ruhig
in der Kurve zu sitzen also mich wirst
Du hören heute Abend keine Stunde mehr
dann rollt hier der Ball 7000 deutsche
Fans dürften dabei sein ich denke es
wird ein klares 3:1 für Deutschland
Johannes sagt 4:0 aber ich glaube es
muss ein Sieg werden und das wissen die
Spieler und es wird ein tolles Spiel ist
mir egal Hauptsache weiter ich will
nicht nachher vorhin nach Hause gehen
Russland die Spannung steigt im
albrecht-stadion ist alles angerichtet
so jetzt werfen wir mit dem Blick auf
die beiden anderen entscheidenden WM
Spiele war besonders spannend heute
Nachmittag in der Gruppe F drei
Mannschaften mit der Chance aufs
Achtelfinale dabei Kroatien und Belgien
im direkten Duell am Ende ein 0:0 und
das bedeutet Kroatien weiter Belgien
raus
der zweite gegen den Dritten der letzten
WM für ein Team ist kein Platz mehr in
der Ko-Runde es ist Belgien die Kroaten
und ihr Lenker Luka Modric mit der
besseren Spielanlage doch im Abschluss
selten zwingend genug sein Schuss
pariert von Kultur ein Unentschieden
würde ihnen reichen Belgien muss
gewinnen und bringt nach der Pause
lukako fürs Sturmzentrum diesen bieten
sich in der Folge mehrere große Chancen
posten die Roten Teufel mit vielen
verzweifelten Angriffen 89 Minute wieder
kann Lukaku den Ball nicht über die
Linie befördern
er hätte zum Matchwinner für Belgien
werden können und wird zur tragischen
Figur
romelo Lukaku der ewige Geheimfavorit
verabschiedet sich nach der Vorrunde und
nach inständigen beten ihrer Fans
schaffen es die Kroaten als Gruppenseite
ins Achtelfinale
Belgien hat also die Chance aufs
Achtelfinale liegen lassen Marokko
dagegen hat sie genutzt durch den Sieg
gegen Kanada der entscheidende Treffer
fiel bereits in der 23 Minute Josef
nesiri zum 2:0 der spätere
Anschlusstreffer für die Kanadier
bedeutungslos nach 36 Jahren steht
Marokko wieder in einem WM Achtelfinale
zum Biathlon Weltcup ein guter Tag für
die deutschen Staffeln im finnischen
Kontiolahti das Männerquartett erkämpfte
sich über die 4x7,5 km einen starken
zweiten Platz und genauso erfolgreich
danach die DSV Frauen über die Firma 6
km Distanz
Schlussläuferin Denise Herrmann W
ick mussten glaube ich jetzt für uns
beim letzten Schießen die Schwedinnen
bereits längst durch Deutschland und
Norwegen gleich auf Denise hermannweg
muss zweimal Nachladen die norwegeren
Tante wollten nur einmal somit leicht im
Vorteil doch dann die Attacke beim
letzten Anstieg die Einzel
Olympiasiegerin kann sich absetzen am
Ende also Rang zwei hinter den
siegreichen Schwedinnen ein gelungener
Saisonauftakt für die deutsche
Mannschaft denn auch die Männer schaffen
den Sprung aufs Podest während ebenfalls
Zweiter hinter dem Quartett aus Norwegen
auf Rang 3 Frankreich
ja und auch morgen wieder viel Sport im
ZDF ab 15 um 15 Uhr der letzte WM
Gruppenspieltag bei uns zu sehen
Dankeschön und jetzt gratulieren wir
noch einem ganz besonderen geburtstags
Kind Jonathan die älteste Schildkröte
der Welt wird sage und schreibe 190
Jahre alt fast zwei Jahrhunderte das
bedeutet 8 britische Monarchen und 40
US-Präsidenten hat die Riesenschildkröte
überlebt seit 1882 wurde Johnson hier
links auf der Insel St Helena vor der
Westküste Afrikas wo 60 Jahre zuvor
Napoleon starb für die Menschen dort ist
das Reptil eine echte Ikone ziert sogar
eine Münze und statt Geburtstagstorte
gibt es Obst seine Lieblingsspeise
gefeiert wird ab morgen drei Tage lang
kühl war es ja schon länger jetzt
beginnt es hier und da auch zu schneien
Details zum Wetter gleich von Katja
horneffer Christian Sievers begrüßt sie
um 21.45 zum heute-journal und Morgen
begrüßt Sie hier Barbara halweg bis bald
[Musik]
guten Abend heute hat es geschneit das
sehen Sie hier in dieser rosa Farbe zum
Beispiel hier der Ostseeküste aber auch
in Sachsen im südlichen Brandenburg bis
nach Berlin das ist nicht sehr viel
Schnee und in der Nacht sieht dieser
Schnee hier in der Mitte weiter nach
Westen auch im nordhessischen Bergland
kann es bis morgen früh weiß werden über
Tag ziehen die Schneefälle dann weiter
westwärts und auch aus Südosten kommen
neue Schneefall heran insgesamt wird das
nicht viel Schnee 12 cm vielleicht in
den Mittelgebirgen sonst bleibt der
Schnee nicht liegen heute Nacht bleibt
es am ehesten trocken zwischen
Ostfriesland und dem Oberrhein südlich
der Donau bildet sich Nebel und das kann
auf Straßen und geh wegen überall glatt
sein denn die Temperaturen sinken in den
kritischen Bereich zwischen plus 4 und
-4 Grad morgen über Tag bleibt es häufig
bei werden knapp über null Grad es gibt
zum Teil Dauerfrost und vier oder fünf
Grad plus gibt's eigentlich nur in
Wasser näher die Sonne tut sich morgen
wirklich schwer und ab und zu fällt eben
etwas Regen Schnee oder Schneeregen und
an dieser Wetterlage wird sich auch über
das zweite Adventswochenende wenig
ändern bei Höchsttemperaturen zwischen
-1 und maximal plus 8 Grad guten Abend